the trip away from the bustle of real
just around the corner is a place where
the Brazilian king came over a century
ago to kick back and relax and it's not
a bad spot to escape to or trying to
write history the training grounds are
sealed off to the public but I still
meet dozens of fans were expecting
nothing less than the title from their
team that's eve of the expectations for
Brazil are huge monta they can't fail
they will become world champions take up
your eyes no but I can't lose and we
can't think they can positive thinking
so failure is not an option lucky I have
press accreditation and so I'm able to
get a bit closer to the silicide so this
is the holy place this is where the
Brazilians prepare to write World Cup
history I've never experienced anything
like it 1800 journalists accredit ated a
Brazil's base camp I asked my Brazilian
colleagues healthy squads dealing with
oppression nobody wants a repeat of the
nineteen fifty world cup and Brazil lost
the final match you stuccos this
comparison that people are drawing is
terrible because it creates mental and
emotional confusion now we have a
problem that nobody expected they are
feeling the pressure because they are
too young our best player Neymar is
spendy Jew first world cup the psyche is
a complex thing that often needs more
pampering than relaxing bath today the
talk is of the coach decision to call in
the team psychologist to offer emotional
support to the players teams press
officer also has ideas and how they can
cope maybe the best way is its create a
kind of self protect
so don't watch so much don't read so
much oh don't hear so much talk between
each other and leave the outside you
know the problem is the journalists and
their endless appetite for stories so we
interrogate midfielder ramires who's
experienced enough to play down the
suggestions the team is cracking up they
thought they were a couple who were very
emotional we were all very tense and
nervous but that's completely normal
wrong body I'm astounded what's
considered normal today the reserves are
out on the field while the starting
eleven are on the batch the training
session is being broadcast live on TV on
like 65 cameras are rolling the whole
world is looking what's happening here
so if they really want to win this cup
their only chance is to cool down and
not to think too much what everybody
expects from them